et on va parler aussi un tout petit mot
de loana mais rachel a une annonce à
faire me dit-on dans l'oreillette de
quoi rager une annonce solennelle à 11 h
40 on ait pas eu huit autour de cette
table 9 pourquoi
robino
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
essentielle
[Applaudissements]
bbb bbb-
je me suis réfugié
le premier le premier bébé de tpm t
people
[Applaudissements]
venez chez daniel rault pouvoir revenir
je n'ai pas bien et tout et moi je parle
pas des précieux mais oui moi je temps
réel et des tic cet humour et fantaisie
on n'a pas nommées par le plan loup de
salon que je te dise la scène féminine
regarde franck tu peux aller les yeux
humides sera ton temps et studio choix
paribas il va être content deere a
doublé tout à gilles beaumian dont nous
parlait vraiment bravo mais je vous aime
elle a grossi et si j'osais pas parce
qu'en 2009 à être gentil tu vas
l'aveyron sera mieux le dire dans
l'émission c puis comme ça en plus après
un scoop pour pour magali berda
puisqu'elle reprend les notes de son
genre son magazine l avez pas marre de
vos amis